let's take a closer look at the winners
and losers from today's interest rate
decision the Holly McKay is a founder
and managing director of the consumer
website pouring money Holly good evening
to you I mean three and five people have
fixed their mortgage is it that big a
deal for most people I think we have to
keep this in perspective for nearly 4
million households tonight they'll be
facing higher mortgage repayments but
interest rates are still incredibly low
so if you take an example of someone
even with a high mortgage on a variable
rate and let's say that Moore was just
250 thousand pounds in practice that
probably means an extra 30 pounds a
month so yes it's gloomy news but we've
got to keep it in perspective
savers I mean the average instant access
account is already paying over Bank rate
at the moment in a lot of cases can they
expect much of this increase to be
passed well I think some of it will be
passed on I think we'll see the top rate
it's about 1.3 percent at the moment we
should expect to see that go up to about
1.4 1.5 percent but people shouldn't
assume that their banks will
automatically pass on this increase so
I'd say wait a week let it wash through
and then do go and check that you're
still in the best place for your savings
what about people coming up for
retirement I mean annuity rates linked
to bond yields interest rates have gone
up that should mean better annuity rate
shouldn't it should be slightly good
news I mean annuity rates are pretty bad
today there's going to be no dramatic
changes but I think people coming up to
retirement can expect to see slightly
improved annuity rate so slightly better
news for savers slightly better news for
people coming up to retirement but again
we keep it in perspective savings rates
are incredibly low today inflation is
much higher than savings rates so
thinking of cash as a safe haven is
something I think we all need to
question I'm one loss or I guess pension
deficits potentially could come down as
a result of higher rates we could see
indeed pension deficits coming down so
as always there are winners and losers I
think the main thing though for people
is be careful of expensive debt and when
it comes to having your money in a
savings account don't assume that
loyalty pays it doesn't with your bank
so shop around Holly McCoy thanks to
that Holly McKay from boring money not
at all boring in person there thanks